days of violent protests against rising
costs have brought parts of ecuador to a
standstill the government is now
negotiating with indigenous groups
leading the demonstrations but can
dialogue curb their anger and will it
help solve the country's economic crisis
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm sahil
rahman ecuador's government is holding
negotiations with representatives of its
indigenous community the talks aim to
end weeks of protest over a sharp
increase in fuel and food prices that
have affected indigenous people the most
after previously accusing strikers of
laying the groundwork for a coup
president guelia molasso has lifted a
state of emergency and made some
concessions but demonstrators say
lasso's concessions are not enough we
begin our discussion in a moment but
first our latin america editor lucian
newman has this report
negotiations to end ecuador's crippling
nationwide strike have been
excruciatingly slow and complex but at
least they've begun
outside of quito's basilica amazonian
guards kept everyone at a safe distance
while supporters of the indigenous lead
strike which is now in its third week
danced for good luck
president guillermo lasso's
representative warned that the
government would not cave into all of
the striker's demands especially a 40
cent cut in petrol and diesel prices
those who agree to everything after them
aren't doing the right thing rather
they're receiving orders that is the
characteristic of a kidnapped government
and we will not be one of those
but indigenous leaders stood firm
our objective is for the wealth of this
country which we too produce
to be redistributed fairly and equally
[Music]
in the absence of a breakthrough
roadblocks that have crippled much of
the economy including ecuador's key oil
industry were reinforced this is the
town of wallo a poor agricultural
community outside of the capital quito
where we arrived a short while ago to
find this huge roadblock leading to one
of the main highways in this country as
well as tires burning and tempers
flaring the residents tell us that just
a short while ago they had a violent
encounter with security forces
[Applause]
we saw an ambulance race off with one of
the injured an elderly man who was
reportedly attacked by riot police
inside his home
gestures say they were fired upon at
close range with tear gas and rubber
pellets
they came here to kill us they have no
compassion for women and children or the
elderly
while scores of security forces have
also been seriously injured in running
battles with protesters the six fatal
victims so far have been demonstrators
sixty-year-old beatrice ramirez insists
their strike is adjust
we work the land with our picks and
shovels to survive we aren't rich so we
need the government to lower the price
of fuel
[Music]
the government has agreed to alleviate
farmers bank debts and improve health
and education services and it's offered
to decrease fuel by 10 cents a gallon
but indigenous leaders say that's not
nearly enough
and so the government continues to weigh
carefully its commitment to imf
austerity measures against a
governability crisis that is worsening
by the day
lucia newman al jazeera quito
so let's bring in our guests on this
edition of inside story in guayaquil
ecuador adrian perez salazar an attorney
and political analyst
in kuenka also in ecuador manuela pique
a professor at the universidad san
francisco de quito and amherst college
and in new york in the us is danny shaw
a professor of latin american and
caribbean studies at the city university
of new york
welcome to you all on this edition of
inside story manuela can i just begin
with you
can you just sum up for us and for our
viewers across the world in 30 seconds
where are we right now in ecuador and
what's going on
so we're going through a national
protest led by the indigenous movement
we're two weeks in now entering day 6
15.
um
the
the roots are many of course but we can
say that the
short run the last two years we are
coming out of a major crisis because of
covid there has been no governmental
support
the hospital system is totally destroyed
dismantled there's no no medicine in the
hospitals
the education system is dismantled um
there are many
problems to get into university and
there are thousands and thousands
hundreds of thousands of students who
cannot enter so
high unemployment on top of that we only
have 30 percent of ecuadorians who
actually have a formal job and how much
i don't know
if i just jump in there
just sum up how frustrated is society
right now
so all of that leads to a lot of
frustration and there is no government
response so the indigenous movement
called for a strike a national strike
two weeks ago and the government the
first day of the strike has detained
illegally kidnapped the president of the
indigenous movement so that led to a lot
of
uh
resentment and even more mobilization
right and then after two weeks of
protest the the president of at least of
10 demands
instead of like seeking to negotiate
trump has sent the military onto people
there are many dads and
people in hospitals so there is a an
anger that is growing and blossoming
among society and we'll unravel all of
that in the next half hour let me bring
in adrian perez salazar i mean how much
of this is about the sort of historical
anger within the country of successive
government as a successive government
not being able to
draw on the aspirations of what the
public wants and how much of it is about
the immediate short-term covid we're now
uh seeing a a war in ukraine which is
impacting globally there's short-term
and long-term issues here where do you
uh adrian
see
the problem
uh being embedded
thanks for having me i believe this is
most mostly short-term issues that are
happening here
uh mr isa the the leader of the
indigenous movement tried to do a strike
a few months ago and it was completely
unsuccessful and that's what was because
a lot of the issues that were happening
that are happening now
were not were not as prominent then so
it were not this is you know
there is always been a a lot of issues
of economic disparity in ecuador of
economic inequality lack of access to
education and so forth but what is
sparking this particular protest right
now is is very very concrete
political and economic circumstances
economic were there's a growing
discontent on
rising food prices
there is a also there's been also a wave
of high crime which has not been
properly controlled by the government so
all of these issues have caused that the
government which was very popular a few
months ago now has a 70 percent
i'm sorry a 70 disapproval rate
however and and here's where i'm gonna
disagree with uh with miss
manuela is that uh
the the amount of violence that
these protests have sparked are
completely disproportionate with what
the public sentiment is and i'm not this
is not speculation there has been a
there is uh
a
a poll that has been conducted a couple
days ago
uh 80 percent of equilibrium people are
disagreeing with the strike
61 of ecuadorians don't believe the the
the
the demands are legitimate and 76
percent of them disapprove of the
tactics used by the the protesters we're
talking about tactics that have gone as
far as poisoning a a a a city water
supply the city of ambato they use motor
oil too and 25 percent of the portable
water now it's poisoned
they've attacked military convoys
so the the
you know the explanation
at least in my eyes is that yes there's
been a growing discomfort and a
resentment against the government but
this has been channeled for political
gain and what's a political gain it's
they're trying to overthrow the the
president okay well let me bring it in
let me bring in danny shaw here because
it's easy perhaps to see a view a little
bit further away danny in terms of
whether you know as uh adrian has just
mentioned you know there is this perhaps
feeling that the government needs to go
the president needs to go
and those are the aims of some members
of the senate at the moment
politically have they just jumped onto
an opportunity
to see the frustration of the indigenous
communities or is it a little bit more
complicated than that
this is a class showdown this is an
anti-imperialist showdown
the most vulnerable sectors of the
ecuadorian population are sick and tired
of being sick and tired they're sick of
a neoliberal government led by guillermo
lasso formerly by lenin moreno
that represents an interruption to the
citizens revolution
a movement led by rafael correa that was
in power before
lenin moreno which paid
a great amount of attention to
the most vulnerable sectors of the
population the afro ecuadorians the
indigenous population the working
populations and now we see
this neoliberal cabinet which
prefers to serve a foreign debt a debt
to the international monetary fund
and the world bank instead of servicing
the everyday people so these alarmingly
high gas prices inflation violence
within the prisons a hike in crime it's
clear that the neoliberal paradigm has
failed and that's why we have hundreds
of thousands of ecuadorians in the
streets up against the greatest amounts
of repression in the militarization of
the country's police force okay well
adrian's disagreeing with you but i want
to just quickly go back to uh manuela
because that's part of the issues and
we'll deal with them one at a time one
of them is about fuel um ecuador itself
is an oil producing country uh some 8.27
million barrels of crude reproduced um
and therefore
there is the revenue for the government
to improve life for ecuadorians one of
the um
demands of the indigenous communities is
to stop drilling
and to stop producing oil on indigenous
land if you don't have the revenue how
do you improve people's lives because
you need money for it don't you manuela
it's been 50 years that ecuador exports
oil and there has been no benefit for
communities but the the demand is not to
stop oil it's to stop the expansion of
the oil frontier and in part particular
to ex to stop the expansion of the
mining frontier on water sources in the
mountains
the problem of drilling in ecuador or
mining in ecuador is that there is never
community consultation
prior and informed consent from the
communities which is in the law in
ecuador it's in international law and
the government
gives concession illegally without
commun uh
having the consent of the community so
that's a major problem
and ecuador is a dollarized economy and
ecuadorians are migrating to the u.s the
remittances have increased 30 last year
to try to get money for their families
meanwhile the president of ecuador who's
a banker is involved in the pandora
papers right and has been
evading money to fiscal paradises in the
us to the dakotas to florida
and taking the money away from the
countries that people are migrating
taking risks dying on the way migrating
illegally to send money back in dollars
back in because we do not produce our
own money so there is an inequality of
the poor trying to make money and the
rich taking the money away from the
country uh adrian this is about mining
well i think partly i think some people
might say it is about mining slightly
because
danny wouldn't you agree that that
neighboring countries like peru having
the same problem as many other countries
across the world are rising gas prices
there are protests about uh inflation
you know food is or certainly
the grain that uh the world produces in
europe isn't getting to the right
markets as such
is it is it about oil is it about food
and fuel do are you not experiencing as
a country the same things that other
countries are facing right now what
makes ecuador so different
ecuador has a long history of
mobilization
against inequality from 1999 to 2005 we
saw the ecuadorian people topple
three presidents
we see massive changes in the region we
see the first leftist president in
neighboring colombia
we see new dialogues with the venezuelan
government about getting their oil onto
the international market particularly
from france and emmanuel macron
we've seen
strong anti-imperialist movements in
power now in bolivia in nicaragua
we saw this summit of the americas
failure in los angeles a few weeks ago
and it's clear that the ecuadorian
people
are clamoring for more unity more
integration
more subsidies more social benefits in
the government of guillermo
lasso in this uh banco crossing or this
uh bankracy as they say in ecuador is
moving further and further towards
austerity programs and structural
adjustment programs which is against the
will of the
masses of people in the streets of
ecuador uh adrian can i bring you in
here about
about the sort of the inequalities
between those that live in the country
and those that live in urban areas in
the city is there not also a racial
divide there's the indigenous
communities in the country who are seen
as those that have to provide for those
in the urban areas and and you've there
have been uprisings before haven't they
in the 1990s and what 1994 as well
that's highlighted the inequalities that
indigenous communities feel
there are very strong very prominent
structural issues and ecuador of
inequality and a lack of access to
opportunities that's not being debated
here that's that's a problem that's very
real
the issue is that to try to explain
what's happening right now only by
appealing to those factors is akin to
trying to explain a plane crash by
appealing to gravity you know these
issues have been here all along now the
question is what's happening right now
what are the what is the intention of
these particular actors at this moment
what are they trying to do and what i
what i believe and i i strongly disagree
with some of
the the things that are insane there has
not been a huge hike in fuel prices that
quite the opposite you know i'm going to
put some context here some actual
numbers
uh in in ecuador we're going to have
three brands of fuel it's called
eco-pays
extra and super
the tool the two
first the dimension have lower octane
edge and the third one is a high octane
it's a better quality for you know
better better uh higher
quality vehicles
and the the first two uh the price has
been completely frozen there has been no
increase in fuel prices in these two and
it's only in the third one which is only
consumed by the urban elites that
there's been there's been an increase in
prices so it's completely ludicrous it's
completely absurd to believe that this
is caused by
as it's been said right now that by
higher fuel prices well you you have the
fuel prices as one issue but then you
that in itself has an impact on food
prices when you're trying to move move
move food around the country or bring it
in manuela you're sort of shaking your
head just just come in and on that chat
yeah i just want to clarify maybe for
the audience ecuador is a country where
indigenous slavery was legal until 1964.
1964 indigenous peoples were legally
freed up from slavery they were sold
with the land until then so of course
there's structural problems from before
but when you have a near liberal
president right who's governing for the
one percent
who has all his millions of dollars
billions involved in the pandora papers
and who's not listening to the
population
who has problems with the increase of
price not accessing university not
accessing health and then there is a 10
point list so it's not just fuel it's
not just food it is and it is a global
problem since the war in ukraine but
there are 8 other points beyond fuel and
food that have to be taken into account
and the rights of nature and the right
to clean water are other points that we
need to talk about ecuador is a
milestone globally for establishing the
rights of nato of nature
constitutionally legally and many other
countries have followed since 2008 we've
been expanding the rights of nature and
here we have a government who promises
to develop the nation by doubling oil
drilling in the amazon that is not the
solution we are all trying to protect
the amazon to protect the future of the
planet and he wants to double oil
drilling in the amazon without
indigenous consent okay so adrian where
where does this then lead or what
options does the president have right
now because obviously there's a great
deal of anger on the streets
okay i i just want to very quickly
respond to a point by manuela yeah okay
if the if environment is such a big
concern then it makes no sense to
increase fuel subsidies fuel subsidies
are
by definition bad for the environment
they increase the consumption of fuel
and they can increase global warming
and
it you know
the issue with the fuel subsidies is
that they're disproportionate favor they
they
disproportionately favor the top 15
percent of ecuadorians which which are
the the wealthy urban elites it makes no
sense
if you try to solve these economic
disparities if you're trying to solve
environmental problems there's no sense
in insisting in higher field subsidies
the only reason why field subsidies have
become this railing flag is because they
know that they're incredibly hard to
sustain
and i'm going to give you some hard
numbers right now uh
with the new increase with the increase
on international fuel prices right now
uh
the ecuadorian government needs to spend
over three billion dollars in subsidies
which is equivalent it's almost
according to what they have to spend for
the healthcare system which is three
bill 3.16 billion dollars it's almost
what they need to spend for to keep the
security or armed forces and police
which is 3.3 billion dollars
so it's it's a completely unreasonable
demand if mr isa and and the indigenous
leaders were they were that concerned
about the the welfare of of their
communities what they would ask is an
end of fuel subsidies which benefit the
urban elites and they will redirect that
money to other issues such as education
such as security such as for example
better
better uh uh
subsidies for for uh agricultural
products for for for agricultural inputs
okay so it's to me it's it's very clear
what's happening here okay
sorry if you're looking i've got to jump
in i want to get danny in here because
obviously danny you know we can talk
about oil we can talk about the economy
but we also need to talk about the role
literally of the indigenous community
from from your perspective because they
have since 1964 been able to assert
themselves in a way that very few
communities and minority groups that
other countries around the world have
been able to as a collective group
negotiate make the government sit and
talk to them that has taken time
where do you think the negotiations are
right now in terms of the way they're
talking to each other
leonidas isa and the konai said last
night they'll be back in the streets
today they've continued to call for
peaceful civil disobedience across the
the country
um overwhelmingly the repression has
come from the government side
we've seen five protesters killed uh so
far
we've seen
how many hundreds and hundreds of
protesters uh openly uh wounded uh
injured uh
imprisoned
so
there's an informational war right now
going on in ecuador and throughout the
world really they're trying to pin all
the violence on the protest movement
trying to give carte blanche to the
state security forces to continue to
carry out this repression and i think we
have to keep coming back to the wider
geopolitical significance of ecuador the
citizens revolution said that the u.s
military would no longer have uh bases
in manta in ecuador now with guillermo
lasso
there's talk of a galapagos island u.s
military base so there's a lot at stake
here beyond just the bread and butter
issues we've been discussing do you
think the uh
the recent uh meeting uh of the americas
in
uh la was formative or certainly
positive in terms of uh
moving ecuador's aims forward and what
the in what the president wants for the
country
well guillermo lasso is very isolated in
los angeles
most of the americas and dozens of
nations from the caribbean boycotted
this quote-unquote summit of exclusion
or the summit of the americas as they
tried to call it and i think this was a
great uh failure so guillermo lasso was
more and more isolated there's very few
right-wing u.s leaning presidents left
in the region and even guillermo lasso
has opened up to the chinese because he
understands as well that the future is
increasingly multi-polar and not a
unipolar world dominated by the u.s okay
i'm going to give the last word to
manuela as we come to the end of our
program manuela never enough time in the
day really for this sort of a program
the debate is so long and expansive but
in terms of where you see the next few
days going
um how do you see any sort of
negotiation happening between indigenous
communities in the government or are we
set for weeks or months of civil unrest
it's very tricky to see the end of it
it's the longest indigenous surprise
that i have witnessed in 25 years in
ecuador
the president
has accepted to dialogue with the
indigenous movement but he did not show
up he sent his ministers and we're
seeing very little progress in the
official dialogue that started last
night
there is increasingly protest there were
more
protests yesterday than any other day in
the rest of the country it's a very
diffused protest and increasingly
uncontrollable so i foresee this could
last even though people are getting
tired and people need to work and the
price of food has skyrocketed because of
the protest
i i foresee many more uh confrontations
before we see a solution well there
unfortunately we have to leave the
conversation that we're having i'd like
to thank all of my guests adrian salazar
manuel pique manuela peak and danny shaw
for joining us on this edition of inside
story thank you very much
and thank you for watching as well you
can see the program again anytime by
visiting our website at aljazeera.com
and for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle there is at aj inside story
from me sahil rahman and the inside
story team here in doha thanks very much
for your time and your company